my mum's a teacher and she currently is
teaching a class of 10 to 11 year-olds
who actually had the pleasure of meeting
yesterday so hello everybody of my mum's
class and one of the tasks so that my
mum gave her class recently was to write
a biography about a well-known person
from pop and apparently in these kids
eyes I qualify as being a well known
person from birth and so some of them
wrote biographies about me and they are
adorable
so I thought it would be fun to take my
favorite bits from these kids
biographies and turn them into one long
cohesive biography about me
written by ten-year-old charlie joseph
mcdonald is a 20 year old person who is
a famous youtuber he's got over a
million subscribers on YouTube and is
the most popular youtuber in the world
for his unusual videos he once took
three bites out of a lemon then puked
out the lemon he has just over a million
subscribers many people all over the
world what is funny but slightly weird
videos I love how brilliantly honest
kids are about this kind of stuff it's
just great in the late 1990s on the 1st
of October Charlie was born in Bath
Somerset Engelland during his G cfcs
Charlie got a bit bored and wanted
something to do and got into making
videos when Charlie was in year 11 and
only the age of 16 he made his first
youtube video which was a trailer for
Zelda Ocarina which he describes to this
day a pretty rubbish the thing that
persuaded Charlie do be a YouTube hit
that he saw people do their own blogs so
he wanted to do it he said and this is a
direct quote I did the videos on my own
because I want to put in my own ideas
not no one else's ideas I've noticed
that I didn't cite a source for that
quote but I have said things along those
lines before so it's fine macdonald
posted a big range of videos on the site
including his very popular duet with
myself i liked that they used just
mcdonald bear that's very professional
this video how to be english was
featured on The Oprah Winfrey Show it
actually never was but professional
journalists have made that mistake
before so I think it's perfectly fine
that a 10 year old also would he made
something called Charlie is so bored
like they were the videos he did when he
was bored charlie is so bored like is
the most subscribed channel in the UK i
love these kids they just think I'm like
the most popular youtuber in the entire
world it's great Charlie has a band
called channel on and he is selling his
album
line all of the band members die to this
band is made up of the following members
Charlie McDonnell and that's the only
band member that is listed I think this
person just to get rounded finishing
there's Charlie's mum said he is
literally mobbed by fans when she walked
with him in LoDo many of the fans are
girls and most of them sent him email
asking him to marry them most of you do
that I think people always ask him to
marry him but I don't know if it's for a
joke again brilliant kid honesty charlie
is the newest celebrity I win I'm the
newest he is a very fun and cool person
who makes a very funny videos he will be
remembered as one of the best youtubers
in the world for his fantastic all-caps
videos and will always be a great role
model for all of the other youtubers and
kids I love these kids so much I don't
think it's a problem at all that these
kids make some of the mistakes that they
do because you know making mistakes is
how you learn and they're only 10 so is
funny I just think they're really sweet
and adorable and I feel flattered that
they would even write biographies about
me at all so thank you everybody in my
mum's class it is a bit difficult for me
to make videos in this tiny little
girl's bedroom but I'm doing the best I
can so thank you for watching and I'll
see you next week for a really boy
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you bike cool new video on
the N screen we're gonna see what
Charlie's been up to he got up to a
million subscribers whoo macaw boy
Charlie represent 2011 imponderable joy